- [Together] Pizza, pizza,
pizza, pizza, pizza, pizza, pizza
- [Woman] It's a pizza!
(laughing)
- I really love pizza, I
feel like I can have it
breakfast, lunch, dinner.
- My uncle owns a pizzeria,
pizza is my favorite food.
- I've been eating pizza probably
three to four times a week.
- I've never faced a pizza
that I couldn't conquer.
(folk music)
- Oh!
Oh!
- What the heck?
- Oh my god.
- Too much.
- Oh my, are you kidding me?
- It's a pizza sandwich.
- There's a bunch of different pizzas.
- Pizza-ception, it's pizza inside pizza.
- And it appears to be a grandma
pie, with a regular pizza,
and then some sort of beautiful
crust situation on top.
All of which are great on their own,
and I bet they're better together.
- A toast, bah!
- Cheers.
- Two, three,
- All one time?
- This is intimidating.
- It tastes like a pizza
hybrid with a garlic knot.
- I really like the tomato
sauce, it's very light
but really nice.
- Mhm.
- Look at all the garlic on there.
- Yeah.
- This is my kind of pizza.
- Definitely have the
sauce and cheese right.
- Yeah.
- But it's just too soggy and doughy.
- Is this pizza too?
- Yeah, it's pizza.
- This is getting to be a lot,
wait what happens if I just
oh, that's not, no this is.
- I think I prefer the
crust of the bottom,
but I like the flavor of
the pizza in the middle.
- This is like a lunch
pizza, I'm like on the go.
- The bottom one's just
a plate, if you will.
A pizza plate.
- This is the appetizer.
- See, this is approachable.
- This is easy.
- This is just like, oh I
know what I'm doing here.
- This is garlic bread.
- This is starting to feel
like 4 a.m in college.
- And you get all the garlic smell,
so you're thinking it's garlic bread,
and then when you eat it you're just like
- Really sad it's not garlic bread.
- It's just more crust.
- I'm just gonna discard
this and go straight
for the main course.
- Yeah.
- This pizza would be the garlic pizza
with the crust from the bottom pizza.
- I would order this for
every party I get invited to,
for every party I throw.
- Just have a normal pizza
and wings, this is too much.
- You just have a little bit of everything
going on here, and it's perfect.
- Man, this is the ultimate,
ultimate pizza box.
- This, I wanna like,
- Ultimate.
- Yeah.
- You're choosing your own
adventure with this thing.
- When you're with a group of people,
and everyone's like no, we
probably only need two pizzas,
little do they know.
- Surprise.
It's not just one pizza.
(folk music)
(singing high operatic note)